Ou trois nombres croissants.
C'est le troisième exemple de biais de confirmation :
accepter les données en tant que preuve,
même si elles sont cohérentes avec des théories rivales.
Les données ne sont qu'une collection de faits.
Une preuve, ce sont des données appuyant une théorie et écartant les autres.
La meilleure façon d'appuyer votre théorie
est d'essayer de la réfuter, de se faire l'avocat du diable.
Testez quelque chose comme 4, 12, 26.
Si vous obtenez un oui, cela réfuterait votre théorie
de trois nombres pairs successifs.
Pourtant, ce test est efficace
car si vous obtenez un non, cela réfute « trois nombres pairs »
et « trois nombres croissants ».
Cela réfuterait les théories rivales, mais pas votre théorie.
Mais la plupart des gens ont trop peur de tester 4, 12, 26
car ils ne veulent pas obtenir de oui
et prouver que leur théorie préférée est fausse.
Le biais de confirmation, ce n'est pas que ne pas chercher de nouvelles données
mais aussi mal interpréter les données quand vous les recevez.
Cela s'applique en dehors du labo à des problèmes importants et réels.
En effet, Thomas Edison l'a dit :
« Je n'ai pas échoué,
j'ai trouvé 10 000 solutions qui ne fonctionnent pas. »
Découvrir que vous avez tort
est la seule façon de découvrir ce qui est correct.
Disons vous êtes directeur des admissions d'une université
et votre théorie est que seuls les bons étudiants
issus de familles riches réussissent.
Vous n'admettez que de tels étudiants.
Et ils réussissent.
Mais cela est aussi cohérent avec la théorie rivale.
Peut-être que tous les bons étudiants réussissent,
riches ou pauvres.
Mais vous ne testez jamais cette théorie car vous n'admettez aucun étudiant pauvre
car vous ne voulez pas que votre théorie soit démentie.
Qu'avons-nous appris ?
Une histoire n'est pas un fait car elle pourrait ne pas être vraie.
Un fait ne sont pas des données,
cela pourrait ne pas être représentatif si ce n'est qu'une seule donnée.
Et les données ne sont pas une preuve --
cela pourrait ne pas appuyer votre théorie
si c'est cohérent avec des théories rivales.
Que faire ?
A un point d'inflexion dans votre vie :
décider d'une stratégie pour votre entreprise,
d'une technique parentale pour votre enfant
ou d'un régime pour votre santé,
comment vous assurer que vous n'avez pas une histoire,
mais une preuve ?
Laissez-moi vous donner trois conseils.
Le premier est de chercher activement d'autres points de vue.
Lisez et écoutez des gens avec lesquels vous êtes ouvertement en désaccord.
90% de ce qu'ils disent pourrait être faux, d'après vous.
Mais et si 10% était vrai ?
Comme l'a dit Aristote :
« C'est la marque d'un esprit cultivé
qu'être capable de nourrir une pensée
sans la cautionner pour autant. »
Entourez-vous de personnes contestant votre opinion
et créez une culture qui encourage activement le désaccord.
Certaines banques souffrent de la pensée de groupe,
les employés ont trop peur de questionner les décisions de prêt des dirigeants,
contribuant à la crise financière.
Dans une réunion, nommez quelqu'un avocat du diable
allant à l'encontre de votre idée.
Ne faites pas qu'entendre un autre point de vue,
écoutez-le également.
Comme l'a dit le psychologue Stephen Covey :
« Écoutez avec l'intention de comprendre,
pas l'intention de répondre. »
Il faut apprendre d'un point de vue divergent,
pas offrir des arguments contre.
Ce qui nous mène aux autres termes oubliés de l'inférence bayésienne.
Car les données vous permettent d'apprendre,
mais l'apprentissage est relatif au point de départ.
Si vous démarriez avec la certitude que votre théorie devait être vraie,
votre point de vue ne changera pas --
quelles que soient les données que vous voyez.
Seulement si vous êtes vraiment ouvert à la possibilité d'avoir tort
pouvez-vous jamais apprendre.
Comme Léon Tolstoï l'a écrit :
« Les sujets les plus difficiles
peuvent être expliqués à l'esprit le plus lent
s'il n'en a pas déjà formé une idée ;
mais la chose la plus simple
ne peut être expliquée à l'homme le plus intelligent
s'il est fermement persuadé qu'il sait déjà. »
Deuxième conseil : écoutez les experts.
C'est peut-être le conseil le plus impopulaire
que je puisse vous donner.
(Rires)
L'homme politique britannique Michael Gove a dit que les gens dans ce pays
en avaient marre des experts.
Un sondage récent a montré
que plus de gens feraient confiance à leur coiffeur --
(Rires)
ou à un homme dans la rue
qu'aux dirigeants de leurs entreprises,
services de santé et organismes de bienfaisance.
Nous respectons une formule de blanchiment des dents
découverte par une mère
ou nous écoutons l'opinion d'une actrice sur la vaccination.
Nous aimons les gens qui disent ce qui est, qui suivent leur instinct
et les disons authentiques.
Mais l'instinct a ses limites.
L'instinct ne vous dirait jamais de donner de l'eau à un bébé atteint de diarrhée
car cela sortirait de l'autre côté.
Mais l'expertise vous dit le contraire.
Vous ne laisseriez pas un homme dans la rue vous opérer.
Vous voudriez d'un expert ayant passé des années à opérer
et connaissant les meilleures techniques.
Cela devrait s'appliquer à toute décision majeure.
La politique, les affaires, les conseils de santé
nécessitent de l'expertise, comme la chirurgie.
Pourquoi se méfie-t-on tant des experts ?
Une des raisons est qu'ils semblent coupés de la réalité.
Un PDG millionnaire ne peut pas parler au nom d'un homme ordinaire.
Mais la vraie expertise se trouve dans les preuves.
Les preuves soutiennent l'homme ordinaire
contre les élites.
Les preuves vous forcent à prouver les choses.
Les preuves empêchent les élites d'imposer leur point de vue
sans preuves.
Autre raison de la méfiance envers les experts :
différents experts disent des choses différentes.
Pour chaque expert affirmant
que quitter l'UE serait mauvais pour la Grande-Bretagne,
un autre expert affirme que cela serait positif.
La moitié de ces soi-disant experts aura tort.
Il faut admettre que la plupart des publications écrites par des experts
sont incorrectes.
Ou au mieux, affirment des choses que les preuves n'appuient pas.
Nous ne pouvons pas croire un expert.
En novembre 2016, une étude sur la rémunération des cadres
a fait la une à l'échelle nationale.
Même si aucun des journaux ayant couvert l'étude
n'avait jamais vu l'étude.
Elle n'était pas encore publiée.
Ils ont cru en son auteur,
comme avec Belle.
Nous ne pouvons pas nous plus choisir les études
qui appuient notre point de vue --
cela relèverait du biais de confirmation.
Cela ne signifie pas que si sept études montrent A
et trois études montrent B,
alors A doit être vrai.
Ce qui compte, c'est la qualité
et non la quantité d'expertise.
Nous devrions faire deux choses.
Un : nous devrions examiner de façon critique
les qualifications des auteurs.
Comme vous examineriez de façon critique
les qualifications d'un chirurgien potentiel.
Est-il vraiment un expert sur la question
ou a-t-il un intérêt personnel ?
Deux : nous devrions prêter une attention particulière
aux publications publiées dans les grands journaux académiques.
On accuse souvent les chercheurs d'être coupés du monde réel.
Mais ce détachement vous donne des années à passer sur une étude.
Pour obtenir des résultats,
pour écarter ces théories rivales
et pour distinguer la corrélation et la causalité.
Les journaux académiques nécessitent un examen des pairs
où une publication est rigoureusement examinée
(Rires)
par les plus grands esprits au monde.
Meilleur est le journal, plus les standards sont élevés.
Les journaux les plus élitistes rejettent 95% des publications.
Une preuve académique n'est pas tout.
Une expérience dans le monde réel est également cruciale.
Un examen par les pairs n'est pas parfait, des erreurs sont commises.
Mais quelque chose de vérifié est mieux
que quelque chose qui ne l'est pas.
Si l'on se fixe sur une étude parce que l'on aime ses conclusions,
sans considérer de qui elle est ou si elle a été vérifiée,
il y a un énorme risque que cette étude soit trompeuse.
Ceux d'entre nous qui affirment être des experts
devraient reconnaître les limites de notre analyse.
Il est très rarement possible de prouver ou de prévoir une chose avec certitude,
pourtant il est si tentant de faire une déclaration radicale, sans réserve.
C'est plus facile d'en faire un gros titre ou de la tweeter en 140 caractères.
Mais même des preuves peuvent ne rien prouver.
Elles peuvent ne pas être universelles,
ne pas s'appliquer dans tous les contextes.
Ne dites pas : « Le vin rouge fait vivre plus longtemps »
quand le vin rouge est seulement corrélé à une vie plus longue.
Et seulement chez des gens qui font également du sport.
Troisième conseil : marquez une pause avant de partager quoi que ce soit.
Le serment d'Hippocrate dit : « En premier lieu, ne pas nuire ».
Ce que nous partageons est potentiellement contagieux,
soyons très prudents quant à ce que nous partageons.
Notre objectif ne devrait pas être les j'aime ou les retweets.
Autrement, nous ne partageons que le consensus,
nous ne remettons en question la pensée de personne.
Autrement, nous ne partageons que ce qui sonne bien,
peu importe qu'il y ait des preuves ou non.
Nous devrions plutôt nous demander ceci :
si c'est une histoire, est-elle vraie ?
Si oui, est-elle appuyée par des preuves à grande échelle ?
Si oui, de qui est-elle, quelles sont ses qualifications ?
Est-elle publiée, le journal est-il rigoureux ?
Posez-vous la question à un million de dollars :
si la même étude était écrite par les mêmes auteurs,
avec les mêmes qualifications,
mais parvenait à des résultats contraires,
seriez-vous encore prêt à la croire et à la partager ?
Traiter tout problème -
le problème économique d'une nation ou un problème de santé personnel -
est difficile.
Nous devons nous assurer que nous avons les meilleures preuves pour nous guider.
Ce ne peut être un fait que si cela est vrai.
Ce ne peut être une donnée que si cela est représentatif.
Ce ne peut être une preuve que si cela appuie quelque chose.
Et il n'y a qu'avec des preuves que nous pouvons passer d'un monde post-vérité
à un monde pro-vérité.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)